what's up everyone welcome to simulation
we are in Chicago still we are going to
be talking about diversity inclusion
women we are sitting down with Michael
Donnelly that's thanks for coming on the
show absolutely super excited to be here
thanks for making the time to see me
while you're in town it who did we get
introduced to each other by again I
don't even remember and now you're
putting me on the spot yeah I forgot to
but I'm so grateful for their
introduction maybe I remember the
importance of the introduction because
but I remember who we might have
interest in yeah
but it was like Michael's got an
incredible vision can you help her and I
was like yes how can I help and then now
we're here together which is fantastic
because you're based in Chicago so
Michael is the founder of the forward
collective for women and diversity and
we're gonna be talking about
professional inclusion it's gonna be a
lot of fun yes and we always do so
thanks for coming on the show
awesome all right so your backgrounds
cool because you were figuring out that
this is this is really actually
interesting business gets done when
people have fun I learned that the hard
way and the easy way thank you so I
spent some time working in events
working in interactive and experiential
marketing predominantly at conferences
and festivals and what I noticed is that
the more we get in the same room as the
customers the more relationships are
built and you know we can back and forth
email exchange we can tweet at each
other we can do all that and yes there
are digital relationships but nothing
will ever surpass that handshake like we
just had we create moments and memories
together and that translates into why we
want to work together why we get excited
about building new ideas why you know
that I got a guy thing that I got a gal
thing that I
person thing is a reality when you can
associate memories or shared experiences
it almost humanizes us further and it
brings us closer together to the people
if you know how can you build with
people if you're not at their essence at
their core with them yeah and with all
of the virtual workforces virtual
assistants understanding that we've
separated out to a certain extent and
delegated or translated getting more
work done and optimizing but then you're
seeing the resurgence of community
through our co-working spaces so
although your company may have people
that work all over the world your team
members don't have to work from home
although working from home is nice as a
solopreneur for the past couple of years
and on and off with different ventures
it gets lonely like you want to be
around other people we feed off of that
creative energy so that's why we're
seeing co-working spaces blowing up
shared offices aren't a new thing but
the community aspect of a shared office
a shared office used to be well I just
have this address that I share with a
couple other people who have rooms in
this building now it's let's grab a
happy hour let's go to camp we work I
mean they're doing all of these concerts
and you know the volleyball teams and
things like that that you lost when you
were working in such separated cities
through the same mission or same company
so then you made it a you helped
companies realize that this was an
important focus camaraderie yeah yeah I
think my first couple clients came out
of people that I was already working
with surprise surprise that's kind of
how a lot of businesses start you see a
problem and referrals are so important
in this development Lee I think this was
with red suede shoes which was about
four years ago yeah I started this when
I left tech week and the reality was
there's a number of companies that were
like oh we want to get her in clients
her
audience together what are creative ways
so that was something where instead of
just doing your traditional happy hour
what can we add to this happy hour
that's going to make it more memorable
so where's some of this yeah so we have
actually one client is a great example
and I've become very good friends with
their director of marketing Walker Sam's
so during March we did a March Madness
event and they are a PR company so we
had four different marketing executives
talk about video marketing digital
marketing and I don't remember what the
other two I think one was event
marketing actually and then something
else and we had a curated experience
where we would buzz the buzzer you got
15 minutes with each of the expert
coaches we would buzz the buzzer and
then you roundtable moved around to have
more interaction so it wasn't a panel
discussion with four different experts
it was four 15-minute rounds or maybe we
did three to follow basketball periods
because it was March Madness I mean
sports I get it so that was really
interesting and it was lead marketers
from all over the city and it was a way
for Walker sands to show their expertise
to showcase some of their other clients
there was cocktails there is appetizers
all the things that you traditionally
have but you walked away with some new
knowledge and you still got to have that
regular happy our networking element - I
love how we can add creative edges to
the way we generically do our events and
then that adds a whole new like whoa it
makes it more memorable which is kind of
the whole point is to the buzzers and
often people just like jumped out of
their seat like okay it's time to go
yeah so I love I love that like the
premise system is to become more
memorable more unified with your team
and then if you do that with memorable
experiences it becomes even more
ingrained within you I don't even expand
that one step it's not only with your
team that was just an easy example
because it's camaraderie and team
building but also your customer and
audience and community experience so
customer acquisition customer retention
and then team-building are kind of areas
that you see these events popping up
more and more and those are ways that we
can focus on it's not always about just
building your team in growing that
culture and camaraderie although that's
where I spend more time now in the
diversity and inclusion space but
originally it's also about creating
dollars like what what makes you stand
out versus the other professional
services company versus the other
whatever your competition is how do you
differentiate that you know I shake your
hand but then I also I don't just take
you to the box at a Bulls game or the
box that Hawks game we are coming to
talk to me and learning something and
then we're hanging out and having some
fun yeah I think it's really important
to do a deep dive into the other
person's soul and I think a good way to
do that is by is by learning knowing
that learning how to do this process of
the quality of your life's quality of
your questions so if you are just
chilling there at the box of the Bulls
game and you're just hanging out
watching the game maybe there's a break
in play and instead of talking about
some surface level stuff be like you
know what do you think so what are you
building into the world like why is this
an important part of your essence you
know why why is this part of your
actualization you know how were your
parents when you were growing up how are
your brothers and sisters like do you
have any fears right now like or
anxieties that you know they've talked
me about your life like and I can be
overwhelming for people sometimes and
diving really deep when we're used to
surface level communication especially
at events and we're used to the buffer
of drinks and I think we're seeing a
transition between how people are
interacting in professional
circumstances although you do still have
a lot of these happy hours the
team-building thing is newer right the
high ropes course the different things
that people are doing and tapping into
those real life questions I would say
that some of these younger generations
have kicked it off and a lot of older
generations or more mature generations
are starting to embrace it what's the
meaning of what I'm doing every day
what's the meaning of life we're not
going to work in the same way of hey I'm
going to work to do this job and I think
that's why although we've known the
importance of diversity and inclusion or
inclusion opportunities for a long time
we're starting to see that transition
we're starting to see companies put real
dollars behind it because there are
studies like McKinsey just put out a
report that diverse companies make 34%
higher revenues but actually that was
the survey from a year or two ago so I'm
sure that's increased or there's
different numbers around it now can we
can we talk about maybe what are some of
the this let's lead into the forward
collective now what are some of the
variables that you think it aunt 'add
when you have diverse companies increase
the bottom line yeah I think it's the
variety of thoughts and I think that's a
really basic way to say it but when you
put even you and I in the same room and
I think it's very interesting because
going back to diversity of thought how
the CEO of Apple are not CEO excuse me
the woman who was promoted to be the
diversity equity and inclusion
represented event at Apple because this
role is really new for a lot of people
she said a true statement that you can
have five got five white guys with blue
eyes in the same room and they will have
diversity of thought but that doesn't do
what we need right now is a culture so
it's complicated because when you say
things like that
it discredits the fact that although we
may be different even though we have
similar skin colors what the big
difference is is having people that have
vastly different backgrounds in the same
room
that come from completely different
upbringing because the challenges then
become I mean you saw it with Pepsi we
saw it with H&M we saw it with all of
these big brands like someone didn't
flag this huge thing that became a huge
cultural issue and that's where we see
once you have different voices different
eyeballs different thoughts in a
different frame we're looking at things
through a different lens I think I got
it around about do the conversation
there I think you're I think you're spot
on there so
mm I was telling you a little bit about
this beforehand but when we had the
opportunity to talk to Jordan Peterson
and I was really trying to see if there
was any research that we could
there exists or that we could go and
start researching about how interesting
it is to have somebody of complete
different thought a different lens of
the way they view the world a different
birth in a different culture in the
world so it's just a completely
different upbringing and in a lot of
respects and so when they come with
their different morals and ethics and
values and philosophies about life to
the company does that then help a lot
because if the person has the same sort
of meritocracy the same background as
the other person it wouldn't it then be
better to add the person that has
completely different values completely
new philosophies and ways of thinking
that could accelerate the company's
bottom line so I was really trying to
dig in and see if that was potentially
one of the reasons why this bottom line
is being increased and so okay so this
is a professional inclusion yeah so
that's actually interesting we were
talking also about just like the
importance of looking at places in the
world like the Koreas and at post Korean
War we have South Korea which is one of
the top ten economies in the world
it's like 11th I think and then North
Korea which is an authoritarian regime
that is not thriving economically
whatsoever which is exclusionary so
professional inclusions now becoming
more and more important you were
touching on it a bit with you know with
Apple continue enriching us about it
because you're hosting these amazing you
would you call them summits or
conferences or summits you're hosting is
amazing summits in Chicago in San
Francisco right now and you've done
three in Chicago two in San Francisco
and these are like panels fireside in
Chicago yeah this September so you
touched on a few things there
and I think what we're starting to
understand is the diversity of thought
is incredibly important but where
five years ago I wouldn't even say the
conversation started then but there were
efforts there are things that have been
happening over the past five 10 years
but where we're seeing more success is
that companies are now prepared more for
that diversity so when it's a team of
all one type adding you know there's the
coin tokenism you know just to check the
box to have these certain people in the
room that doesn't allow for diversity
and inclusion that won't impact your
bottom line there has to be a culture
that is open to sharing and open to the
diversity of thought and welcome miss of
how we express ourselves so in a
boardroom for example if you have one
black person and all white people if
that person is an introvert they're not
going to speak up at the meetings
whether that person is black white asian
short fat tall gay straight whatever you
have to make sure that your culture is
ready for the diversity and that you're
not a wall and there's a couple of
different ways to approach that but I
think we're starting to see it more and
more that yes we know we need diversity
but we need to be acceptance accepting
culturally of that diversity so you
brought up the example of a company
hiring someone from a completely
different country with different values
different different everything well
that's great but not if that person gets
hired and then doesn't have the
opportunity to speak doesn't have the
opportunity to engage doesn't have the
opportunity to share or is facing a wall
every time they try and do that so
there's a lot of value in the fact that
we have to be doing these things but we
have to be doing them with a sense of
well how do we create success
opportunities throughout this process as
well so it's not only about bringing
bringing in diversity of thought but
also about make sure making sure to
foster that diversity of thought while
it's once it's in their culture is
accepting I think everybody you know
most of this comes down to unconscious
bias because I don't think in today's
society at least in today's professional
society that there are a lot of people
that are overtly against diversity it's
just a matter of if you're not overtly
against it what are the things that
you're doing that you are unconscious
about or so your subconscious bias
that's coming out and how do you
recognize those how do you nip those in
the bud because it's not that people
want to be unaccepting and I think
there's a there's a lot of training that
has to happen around that but the
conversation is what's most important is
how are we then collectively making sure
that we're elevating the opportunities
for people to be involved and then
supporting their success journey while
they're there there's another aspect to
this conversation which is this idea of
like the individual the individualism
like it doesn't matter you know black
white gay straight whatever it's like
the individual you know and Martin
Luther King said that he wants a world
where his kids are not judged by the
color of their skin but by their
character and I thought that you know
that idea is something that is very firm
it's very firm that like it doesn't
matter the color or anything else but
your character like what do you think
and like teach me what you think and
I'll teach you what I think and let's
see what we can work together on scent
and certain things I think it's equally
important to remember that the
individual exists meanwhile we're also
trying to be like okay but an individual
from this part of the world is going to
think differently with their unique
upbringing than this other person from
our part of the world taking that on a
micro level from this part of the city
of Chicago versus this part of the city
of Chicago I think that there's a lot of
differences locally that can that can
come up and it's important to figure
those out but figure out ways to foster
the the character growth within yep okay
so now at the summit's we have panels we
have fireside chats you have some of
these creative edges that you've brought
in so like teach us about this because
you like what what is your
edge to the professional inclusion like
why should like people care about the
four o'clock yeah and I think I'm still
working on the best way to define it
right now because it's built by the
community so originally it was something
that I was passionate about but then
it's turned into something that morphs
with the attendees because it's really
the conversation that we're hosting so
we do a full day summit panels fireside
chats keynotes workshops we try and make
sure to always address the one on one
component if we can so we've done one on
one investor meetings we've done
interview prep we've done other things
like that that allow for a specific
learning for individual growth as well
as the one-to-many in the the format of
the general stage that you see our kind
of new way of describing what we're
talking about with professional
inclusion is how we marry your heart
your mind and your bottom line because
those are our drivers our heart in our
mind right what we're thinking how we're
feeling what motivates us what gets
things going but then professionally
it's our bottom line how are we then
turning that into cash and capital so
Ford collective our conversations are
technology politics business development
building and growing teams venture
capital I mean one of our sessions last
year is how to get in scrappy how to
focus on your business every single day
so all the way from entrepreneurs all
the way to your executive audience and
we really make sure that there's a
reason for both people to be in the room
and engaging with each other because we
want to make these connections overall
but then we also want to make sure that
the conversation is valuable for both
sides so it's been pretty cool to watch
that and what our kind of big feature is
making sure that the people on stage
aren't necessarily the ones that you're
seeing at other conferences so after
hosting client events after being
involved in producing events especially
in the technology space I kept seeing
like a women's panel or a black people
panel or a Hispanic panel or Latin X
panel and so many people fighting about
hey it's so hard to find you know
women's speakers it's so hard to find
people of this caliber
that are you know people of color and
it's not you just have to look so we're
working to make sure that we're an
example in the space of we feature
feature by featuring women people of
color and underrepresented groups as the
experts that we are rather than the
boxes that we check there's a lot of
value coming from the stage and in the
conversation and and diversity and
inclusion are a natural part of that
conversation because the people that are
speaking myself and other peers are
people that have experienced some level
of engagement around that conversation I
love that the experts that we are not
the boxes that we check because that's
the that's that's again this that's this
diversity of thought idea is that it is
I am my own individual that I have a
really unique diverse perspective I'm an
expert in this field so that's why
you're calling me here not to check off
some boxes so and I think carrying that
perspective is just that's gonna move us
forward
okay now you mentioned you do everything
from you know this like one-to-many like
1 to 300 but then you also do these
one-on-ones workshops like what are some
of the major action items or takeaways
that come from the forward summits I
think we have a unique value of bringing
people in a room that aren't always
together so when you talk about a lot of
other diversity groups which are
incredibly important we need support
systems we need groups that we can go to
to bounce ideas off of and figure out
you know what's happening with
like-minded individuals but we're
bringing everyone together so we have
you know all different types of people
and all different types of conversations
that allow for unique experiences so I
had a 70 year old white man come up to
me and say this has been one of the most
incredible events that I've been to
because I never get to see people that
are different than me on stage in my in
my field so I'm seeing people that I
would never understand to be this type
of expert because of my historic life I
just was never able to wait
this amazing expertise of this amazing
intelligence from people that were
different than me we've had all
different types of businesses started
out of Ford collective we've had
collaborations born we've had
investments we've had all of those
levels of conversations happening
because we break down those barriers and
I think that's a natural element of
setting the stage that we're all here to
support each other we're here to connect
we're here to learn from each other so
anyone from you know a fortune 500 CEO
all the way down to your early stage
entrepreneurs are having those
conversations and you know from the
people who are speaking all the way to
the person who got their scholarship
ticket that you know we're making sure
that everybody has the ability to
connect and that's why we do like it to
be a bit more intimate and small so
around that couple hundred people and
then breakout sessions and opportunities
to really sit down and say hi how are
you who are you what do you do why do
you do it what what is your passion and
then how do you make money off of that
so like making sure that the
conversation does come full circle it
definitely sounds like a place of
awareness expansion really so it's
probably a really good place for for
young men and older men and young kids
and even people of color to attend but
I'm just saying like interest in general
like wait it would be great for it's a
great way to get your mind expanded to
new areas of thought when you're there
as a white person and you're watching a
bunch of Latinos and Asian's and by
people like be experts in their fields
you're like damn like that's awesome and
then that that that's gonna inspire you
as well and it's unfortunate that that
has to be part of the equation but it
does I think if we look at Wakanda
that's a perfect example of a Wonder
Woman like this year and last year were
the first times in our lives that we saw
a woman superhero and a black superhero
on stage in a blockbuster hit taking
over the world saving the world doing
all these things so if you look like
look at that as an example of what we're
doing on a micro level or on a city by
city level we're featuring people that
have always been
not always but have you know grown into
their levels of expertise based on the
work that's been put in over their
personal lifetimes as the experts that
they are so that people coming up can
see that and people from before can now
reframe their mind if if I've been you
know a white man that's been in business
for 50 60 years and I've only been in
boardrooms with white men when I walk in
and I've had this experience there's a
lot of shock there's a lot of confusion
there's there's a lack of understanding
of how to talk to me I have a friend who
told me a story where every time she
spoke people no one would answer her and
then I heard yeah but when we talked
about it she and I sat down I was like
have you thought about the fact that
you're gorgeous
you show up with your hair out big ready
to go you're probably wearing red
lipstick you're probably walking into
that room with heels like a bat out of
hell in a good way like hey what's up
I'm here ready to rock let's go let's go
let's go
that's a whole nother conversation but
with that part it was have you thought
about the fact that like it's like
walking into a bar it's like they all
think you're hot they don't know how to
talk to you they're nervous around you
and that's a scary way to look at it and
like we want to separate our you know
natural tendencies when we're trying to
be professional but we're human like
life comes out so there's ways to do
that in a respectful way there's ways to
compliment people and or not to
compliment people and I acknowledge that
hey I'm sorry I'm just not used to this
so forgive me like I think I was just
imagining like a guy walking into the
boardroom full of women and the guy
starting to like articulate himself on
the whiteboard and the women just being
like you know let's let's give these
good examples across different
demographics of people to like put
ourselves in the mindset yeah I think
that's a perfect way of thinking about
it and thinking about it like if that
was your daughter if that was your
sister think about us as humans in the
full capacity of what we're doing and
why we're in that room and then be is
honest with yourself and
remember how to act appropriately I
think that's the thing that we get
complimented on a lot for forward is
being straightforward about what we're
talking about when people ask me about
how we have such a diverse group of
speakers and how we find people I say I
ask I say I'm looking for a black man to
speak on this panel because I want that
perspective because I want something
different because I have a white woman
Latin accent and a black woman it would
be really nice to have a man's opinion
it would be really nice to have a white
man's opinion on this topic as well
because diversity is something that a
lot of white people are afraid to talk
about because we don't always feel like
it's our space even as a white woman
sometimes I feel like an impostor
working in diversity initiatives but if
I've struggled I can only imagine what
it's been like for my peers of color and
that's actually the response I get from
my peers of color who are part of
forward who have been in these spaces
like no no we want you we need you we
need everybody to be part of this
conversation to make a change so that be
allies yeah and and I mean we all should
be an ally ship and what do they say in
Wakanda there's a line that they talk
about it it's a we don't need allies and
we need people there fighting next to us
or something and oh yeah
you're not just an ally chillin on the
couch like I'm saying rah rah diversity
no if I look at a marketing piece of
marketing material and it's all white
people if I look at a website and it's
clearly a stock photo if I look at
Hollywood and you don't see any women
that are saving the world and black
people that are saving the world that
this is this is interesting stuff Asian
people have also made it clear that
Hollywood they're superheroes and and I
think that's really important it's
representation representation the media
allies ship a lie ship with an actual
plan of action and a goal not just
saying it out loud I know one of the
coolest examples and I'm totally going
to blank on the names but it was to
women actresses and the white woman got
a much larger offer than the black woman
and the white woman said no we're
getting the same thing we're both
leading roles in this we're both doing
this together I'm not signing the
contract until ours looked the same so
you either bring her up to my level or
we're not working on this too
and that was such an incredible moment
in such a cool time to be able to
witness the fact that you know this
woman was willing to walk away from this
role because her peer was not getting
the same and she was like well this
isn't fair I'm done and now you've seen
it with a lot of other men
starting to do that as well I think
Benedict Cumberbatch was the main guy
that I saw published something about it
or he's like if my female counterparts
aren't getting the same pay then don't
even come don't don't come at me bro
yeah there's lady producers - I gotta be
careful so so this has so many so much
nuances so many variables there's a lot
of personality traits that are being
discussed right now like women being
hiring agreeableness and men being
hiring disagreeableness which ends up
helping in business when you're willing
to be like no I want a better deal
negotiations bring it to the table all
that kind of stuff and then you know and
just like things like that are
interesting that you know that's why you
know women are much you know in that
case better caretaker caretaker and
better like in social setting are able
to be more agreeable and stuff and so
the the ideas that then if there are
some sort of like evolutionarily
psychology based personality traits that
are you know if in a free and open
society without oppression how would
people funnel into these different
traits because then you don't want to
you know you don't want to force you
know men to become more agreeable if
they're already just funneling into
being more disagreeable like there's you
there's rarely male nurses I mean I I'm
around nurses and doctors a lot and I
talk about it and I'm like yeah they're
just they're aren't and and whenever I'm
visiting as well hospitals clinics and I
just don't see as many male nurses and
there's very few actually and so just
just in general the ideas like if men
are have the choice to be a nurse or not
and they're just choosing to not be
nurses why have like affirmative action
programs that like force men to be
nurses I think that's
a really broad statement yeah because
you're talking about now generation
versus a lot of this conversation is
going to be addressed by future
generations
I think stereotypically men aren't
nurses traditionally that scene is a
more feminine role so a lot of men don't
even consider the idea and it's not
because they wouldn't want to or
wouldn't like the job it's because
they're told that's a woman's job it's
also like caretaking like it's just
females are great but that's also a
generalization generalization in the
sense that when we're young girls are
given dolls and boys are given trucks
girls like to play with trucks boys like
to play with dolls but there's a gender
ization that happens at such a young age
that is going to impact the paths that
we take there's also the trauma that's
caused by other people's opportunity to
tell you that you're supposed to do
something one way versus the other and
psychologically if that happens at a
young age and you decide that that's
what what is right what this is what
society is put on you and you don't
bridge out from that then or branch out
from that that's what will happen so I
mean there's the examples you'll hear it
imagining like I'm like a male nurse
like on a billboard like wearing a cape
and being like let's get more like
nurses and this is like guys can be
nurses too and stuff like that makes
sense because you know you can see as
I'm in a mentor role like a guy nurse
and like you can see maybe more male and
males wanting to become caregivers and
caretakers the truck driver like you
don't see as many women as truck drivers
but that doesn't mean women can't be or
don't want to be so it's it's I'm just
wondering where do they naturally funnel
how's that that's the basic question
without it without oppression without
any material back to your how do we
naturally evolve as people when we're
not told what we should be or what we're
supposed to be so naturally I think
we're at an age where we
we are already the earth is impressed
upon us our families our peers and we
now get to decide what we want to think
or what we want to do but there's those
years when you're young that naturally
will we won't know until we start wood
until we stop at using specific types of
toys or specific types of learning tools
for girls and boys at such a young age
because naturally we're already shaping
into separate groups rather than
allowing for your natural tendencies to
come out does that mean it does so it's
like the the if you the equality of
opportunity is presented to every child
and the child just gets to pick and it's
not on purpose
that's just how as the parents were
raised so that's how a lot of times it
gets passed down and I think the more
conscious we are the way nobody should
be becoming a truck driver they're gonna
be it'll all be really interesting how
it turns out right the next couple years
will be telling as we how to made our
cars and services but I think there's a
lot of opportunity of conversation and
interestingly enough there's a lot of
videos that are out right now
educationally around the research of you
know boy stur toys versus girls toys and
you can't tell what a baby is a lot of
times when you meet it for the first
time boy or girl and there's also the
transgender and that whole community and
all of the different nuances in-between
LG teepee cute I'm gonna say it all
wrong ai there's there's a lot of
different subsets of the community or
areas of the community btq ia was oh I
heard a I see even maybe I'm just
thinking artificial intelligence because
that's what I just heard a podcast about
that intersex asexual yeah yeah and and
I mean there's because we're allowing
for conversations people are opening up
to who they are and how they would
naturally tend to and stepping out of
what the world is told then they have to
be okay so then maybe the ideal then
let's see if we can find an ideal is
ideal then to have first I'm an
individual I have my own individual
thoughts my own diverse individual
no matter what other little labels are
attached to me and then I'm born into
the world where I have I see whatever
opportunity that I want that I can
manifest for myself that is it that I'm
not limited to seeing only that I'm not
limited to seeing only certain people of
certain genders or certain skin colors
certain thoughts in positions but but
there are I can become whatever I want
even if we've naturally moved in a
direction I can still become whatever
that I set out to do it's it's very
complicated and new to rabbit holes very
easily and I think that's interesting
because we're hosting a professional
inclusion conference and talking about
business development technology politics
marketing etc and we're talking about
right now how we're raising our kids and
how we're opening up gendered roles
earlier and earlier on so I think
there's no perfect answer and if we
remember that each person is an
individual and we look at people for
their skills the values that they have
what you might what they bring to the
table
that's the best we can do at our stage
of the game and then helping to remove
barriers to what our natural tendencies
might be for the youths that are coming
up so giving out as many opportunities
showcasing embodying I mean be the
change that you want to see in the world
so as you spend time with kids as you
work with different groups as you work
with mature people I think we from a
diversity perspective we also include
ageism as part of like our conversation
because that's a huge thing and I mean
I'm hitting my 30s now and you'd be
surprised I'm in the older side of the
entrepreneurs factor and I'm laughing
they're saying 45 year-old entrepreneurs
are the most successful but you see
heavy in the you know early 20s late 20s
like let's let's you know grind hustle
harder do you know some 18 year olds
that are just crushing it on the
Internet
I was doing really tense work with lots
of followers and stuff and you're like
the most people are 18 yeah I spoke at a
conference with Jake Paul and I'm on
stage with him and laughing and one of
his statements was like you don't need
to go to college kids don't go to
college and he said it in a roundabout
way but it was one of those things I was
like oh my god
it's not that you don't need to and it's
not don't go to college and I was kind
of like I felt like I was picking up the
pieces and I guess you were successful
but not everyone can be an internet
sensation not everyone will have those
successes go for it do what you can but
what you get from traditional school is
different than what you get from
entrepreneurship but also from school of
life and other areas of professional
growth or education like I thought
college was really valuable I also went
back and got my MBA I I learned well in
those situations not everyone does but I
think you see a huge celebration of
people that are self-made and didn't go
to college and didn't do this and you
know heck yes if you can do that but I
don't want to discredit universities and
professional development and all these
other sides of things because there is a
huge value in learning together and in
those educational institutions they're
not perfect but neither is an internet
course like you know there's there's
things that you learn in all of these
different capacities and providing
opportunity to people to know that
something exists outside of the
traditional university path is really
important because a lot of people don't
have mentors or leading figures in those
spaces to be like oh I can do it on a
non-traditional path career path I mean
talking about male nurses if I'm a guy
that wants to be a nurse and my dad
doesn't like that or my mom doesn't like
that or my family makes fun of that that
that's a complicated path to takes but I
think it's same thing with a woman
becoming an engineer exactly and I think
we see more support from our society
right now of women being engineers
versus we do of men being nurses which
is also the you know diversity of other
things that one of the gentlemen that
came to one of our events as a men that
were a man that worked in philanthropy
and he's he's laughing he's like yeah I
don't know like guy but I'm the only old
white guy of my job like it's all women
and it's
you know all different kinds of people
and all different this like I've never
had the diversity problem I've always
been though the joke of Micah I think
I'm laughing at him but for him that was
like a unique thing because in his
career path like he was one of the only
guys in it so there's so many different
ways to look at but I think why this is
important is looking at what
traditionally hasn't been given to
underrepresented groups to people of
color or not even given good way to
think about it's like climbing up the
competence hierarchy like you're trying
to make a lot of impact in the world and
you need your basic needs met so we got
it like get some equality in terms of
just these basic needs that are met and
then once those are met then equality of
opportunity for you to go and pursue
whatever career that is your passion
that you want in the world and then this
sort of the barriers that are in the way
that that that make it more that make it
oppressive in some ways in tyrannical
and it can be fueled by corruption and
greed it can be fueled by just hate
against xenophobia all these different
things some ageism right all these
different things that refute make it
more difficult to climb up the
competence hierarchy and make impact in
the world well and I think it's really
interesting what you brought up is our
basic needs being met and there's a
video on Facebook as well apparently
watch too many Facebook videos lately
it's a gym teacher I believe but they're
outside and it's a diverse group of
young people and he's asking who had
breakfast today take two steps forward
who has two parents at home take two
steps forward who doesn't ever have to
worry about their next meal who doesn't
have to and you see that it's
predominantly the white or Caucasian
kids that are stepping forward and a lot
of the children of color and that's
where the opportunities are going to be
different we're not all starting from
the same place Mitch Kapoor of the que
porra Center out in California and I'm
sure you're very familiar of it with it
sorry okay I need to become more
familiar at the Cape or Center yeah
they're they're doing some incredible
sets that pass along an introduction to
some homies
I fortunate enough to connect with them
they're doing incredible research
leadership thought leadership around
diversity and inclusion initiatives
specifically in the startup and venture
capital space but he wrote an article
and I think I'm gonna mess up the first
by was either missed Einstein's or
undiscovered Einsteins or misplaced
Einsteins and it was about all all of
the youth and where is he what's the
he's right outside the caper centers
right outside San Francisco what is that
ya understand I can't believe I can't
remember this right now and of course oh
yeah yeah yeah so it was about these
undiscovered Einstein's youth from
unrepresented community underrepresented
communities or communities that there
you go Oakland it's across yeah so it's
an open more underserved or
underrepresented area and it was talking
about all of these young people that
have the opportunity to the capacity to
be X but they're not given why so
they're not given the output the two
feet to stand on if you don't have to
for you to stand on there's no way that
you can you know play around and become
this level of yourself so oh my god food
insecurity like you were saying earlier
and also that experiment where they take
the steps to see how where people
actually start I remember someone
teaching you about that and I was like
that's a really good one and and that's
a part of like our white privilege and
understanding that by the way that's in
the u.s. a lot of people typically when
white privilege is said we lose a lot of
the attention of people that maybe find
themselves on the right side of the
political spectrum and I think one of
the ways to maybe real some people back
in is by saying that this is only white
privilege in the white areas of the US
Europe and stuff versus if you look if
you're talking about privilege in Asia
it's typically the white people are at a
disadvantage in comparison Asian people
and if you look at a white person in
Africa you're typically at a
disadvantage the same thing in South
America because you become them exactly
so it's more about a minority a majority
privilege that's that's a clarification
and I think the majority privilege comes
with a sense of privilege and
understanding where you don't
necessarily even see the things that
you're getting that other people aren't
like you can be you can be white in the
US and still be absolutely dirt poor way
poorer than some of the more affluent
maybe black or Latino communities and
then all of a sudden you'd have no
privilege compared to them so that's
always interesting it's an it's an
individual basis that's why you have to
go and have everybody like take these
steps forward economic level of
privilege but then it's also where
traditionally in the US that became
white is because the four founders and
the slavery conversation and all of
those things challenged the
understanding of what you start with
growing up based on the historical
whether that be economic whether that be
how the country was started this and
that like those conversations are gonna
be an entirely new rabbit hole for us
but it's the unconscious bias of not
even knowing that these different
opportunity
growing up I never even thought about
the fact that there might not be
breakfast on the table the next morning
I had a work you know like my my parents
were able to provide that for me but I
went to school with people that didn't
the chosen if it was just sugary cereal
yeah I mean I went to school with kids
that showed up with a bag of pork rinds
for pork rinds for lunch and that was
what they had and it was really crazy
thinking about like I think from a young
age I was always curious about what can
I do what can we do to share and to be
more able to give opportunities to one
another because I've learned a lot of
things from those kids just
conversationally like what's your life
like what's my life what's my
like and how can we help each other and
learn from each other I think that links
us to the the heart mind and bottom line
conversation like I I really love that
yeah how do we really feel each other's
heart energy and really dive into each
other souls as individuals and figure
that out about how to best progress
moving forward in an in an opportunity
equality sort of way and hmm actually
interestingly enough maybe an equality
of baseline is also very important this
equality of Maslow's hierarchy of needs
like just the bare necessities of air
clean air shelter food water electricity
and then come find the best education
find the best healthcare find these best
things for you you're seeing a lot of
companies beef up their benefits
packages because you have you know a
chef that comes in and make lunch you
have a chef that comes in to make dinner
you have your health insurance covered I
think although it's kitschy and fun to
have the ping pong or have these other
things as part of startup culture that's
a way to address other needs that aren't
necessarily met in our normal ways from
our professional lives so yes they
started as a lot of fun and interesting
ways to engage people or to entice
people to come over but they have turned
into another way to kind of check off
the needs that we might have outside of
our traditional work I think I think you
are nailing it because thinking about it
from the perspective of needs that's one
of the reasons why there are people that
just literally live inside of trucks on
the Google campus just because they just
walk to Google every day and then they
just go and do their exercise to shower
their dog stay in care of massage was a
bad dentist yeah just in this
interesting we were just talking about
dynamic architecture with Griffin
Pemberton on the show and like why not
have corporate offices that are
literally unused starting at 6:00 or
7:00 p.m. why not turn those into hotels
at night because they're literally
littered everywhere throughout the
town area so there's all these
interesting ways that humans are not
maximized and shelters are overcrowded
there's lines around the corner if you
drive down the streets of Chicago and
there's hundreds unfortunately of people
sleeping a little much wasted food
sleeping on lower Wacker Drive in the
wasted food and the laws around it I
think I don't have that mental
understanding and that knowledge to be
able to solve those problems in the way
that I would like to but the people that
are it's incredible and and it starts as
the it's funny because there was only
one person at one point then it became
two then it became four and then eight
and sixteen and then it got out of hand
but the thing is just down the street
camps on sighs express reason stuff and
what would what with this whole like
Exponential's thing that I was
addressing it became exponentially to
the point where God to because we did
identify it as a societal problem when
it was starting to happen to the first
person and we didn't build a tight
enough social fabric to maximize the
potential of that person into the world
through their mental or physical
ailments whatever it may be so that is
going to get solved by a lot of
different collective diverse and
multidisciplinary thinkers that are
gonna work together to make that happen
and I think that you know both of us you
know with women and diversity also with
just trying to disseminate these diverse
thoughts from different industries that
wish highlight on the show I think we're
slowly inspiring the next generation of
thinkers and doers to really transition
society into one that is progressing in
ways that are unimaginable today I've
really really strongly am optimistic
about that but I think we have a lot of
things to figure out about like hey I in
robotics and ethics we have a lot of
things to figure out along the way
there's always going to be things to
figure out
I think that the coolest part is when
you actually see some of the change in
impact that's being created whether that
be on a micro-level through one guest at
an event that told me that our panel
discussion and venture capital brought
them to tears because they didn't know
that other people were facing these
issues in the similar way and that was
an Asian man in the the comment that
brought him to tears was by a black
woman so it's like such they're very
different levels of oppression that both
of them have grown up with or
experienced in America his fear turned
into more optimism so we have that level
of impact that's being created on a day
to day basis but the fact that fortune
500 companies fortune 100 companies are
hiring ahead of people and chief
diversity officers you see some of it
for PR of course but it starts for PR
and then it sticks around it turns into
a real thing and some of them are doing
it for the real thing right away and I
applaud that and I think the PR ones if
thoughts increasing bottom line and
figure out how this is happening more
research about more research and more
opportunities of you know we make less
mistakes when we have checks and
balances among people that are different
than us because we see things through
different lenses so the more
conversations that we can have the more
opportunity that we're in the same room
and really building upon ideas the the
better and more optimized the ideas
would be you know you and I probably
just could sit down and talk about what
we could do for the homeless population
and how we could recycle all this food
but as I said I don't have the mental
capacity to take it past here but one of
my peers does and someone who has a
completely different outlook on that
population because I I'm very detached
from it you detach from it we have to
use money as a tool to make that impact
that's one of the things that we talk
about a lot just leveraging money as a
tool to make more impact on them and
then I think that brings us back to the
professional inclusion side of it so why
pay needs to be equal about why people
need to have more opportunities to be in
boardrooms women people of color under
represent
groups because money is power money
equal pay for equal work pay for equal
work
absolutely and 100% I I'm not looking
for any handouts and I don't think
anybody that I'm hanging out with is I
think we're all looking to be recognized
for the experts that we are be paid for
the work that we do and have that be on
a level that's cut you know in
correlation with our peers and in
correlation with the fact that as you
said money kick money is a tool but we
all want access to that tool we all want
access to the power to change the world
and to create impact and to make a
difference and to be able to live and
enjoy our lives at the same time Michael
Donnelly what a freaking pleasure this
has been so much fun yeah thanks for
coming on to the show
we've learned so much across a lot of
different fields and I think this has
been a great episode on professional
inclusion for women diversity for word
collective so definitely check out for
word collective LinkedIn the bio
definitely go check them out we got an
upcoming when are the upcoming logo is
September 13th and then our next San
Francisco one will be March 7th 2019 and
there will be a few other pop-up events
happening in both of those cities
throughout the year and we're looking to
expand we've been in conversations with
DC with Detroit with Toronto with Boston
you know whatever we can make happen we
will and that depends on the people in
the cities that are open to the
conversation and I think there are a lot
of conversations happening around this
so whatever we can do to continue that
and create more opportunities is where
we want to be I would love to see
forward collective also in places like I
don't know Nairobi or in your Hannes
burg or in Cape Town or like in Rio de
Janeiro or in Shanghai Amsterdam like
how interesting would it be to see what
they're for women and diversity what
would their inclusion professional
inclusion look like how would it be
different than the United States started
having some of those conversations with
our parts in different countries and
different large cities across the world
but where I want to be careful is I only
know what I know so I need to have the
right partners and the insights into
those societies because I think that
happens a lot of times when events
expand is you bring what you know from
where you started and you try and apply
that to different cultures and with this
conversation it has to be very nuance to
that culture to that understanding of
what diversity means like we talked
about white privilege well it's not
always white privilege it's us white
privilege and it depends on where you're
from and it depends on your economic
standing and there's all different types
of ways that cultures address these
things so although I would love to
expand you know all over the place and
do this as in ways that work within
their culture and so that that's what's
exciting I'm excited to hear about what
it looks like and learn about what it
looks like in those different places
awesome this has been incredible guys
girls humans everyone humans if you guys
had a good time definitely share with
two other people continue propagating
this type of thought and content sharing
with people also don't just consume go
create with this go write about it go
make a video about it go start something
with it go and make subscribe comment
below powered with it give us your
thoughts below let's do a little
community work also join us on patreon
we're trying to grow this impact more
people with it so join us there thanks
everybody for tuning in and we'd greatly
appreciate it much love